[Music]
the prisoner we snatched last night is a
courier for a man yes eat Khalil who's
the interrogator Alice Racine the
prisoner gave a go order an attack on an
American target in the UK it's thought
to be biological we have two other
members of his mosque in custody and
like you they have a long dark plane
ride in their future tell me the TARDIS
I'm just supposed to deliver a message
important just my personal life Sarah
this is not a secure line we need you
for an emergency assignment in London
we've got a prisoner waiting I'm already
on it
how are you talking about we haven't get
London station so we have been
penetrated
what is going on in London that involves
the CIA and a terrorist strike mi5 is
committing every available asset to this
I think I unlocked a source for a
terrorist he has to be stopped
we need your skill set we need you back
on the front line what's your status
in danger so I want to sounding me I'm
thinking on the only friends you go
we're prisoners gone to ground I do not
intend to let him stay there let the
past go we're just gonna get in the way
when it counts
global viruses are the biggest threat to
mankind each one a ticking bomb
we thought we controlled her once armed
you got five minutes in a different
world he doesn't come to this
we're all in God's hands like to think
we ever said
[Music]
this is Major I'm on-site hmm